GOOD AT ARTICULATING VALUES.
BUT A LITTLE WEAK ON DEFENDING
THEM.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE THE MAYOR OF
ALBANY HERE.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
MRS. MAYOR, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Tucker: WE SHOWED THE VIDEO.
PEOPLE BLOCKING ENTRANCE OF
AMERICANS BECAUSE THEY'RE
DEMANDING CITIZENSHIP AND FREE
STUFF.
WHAT COUNTRY SHOULD PUT UP WITH
THAT OTHER THAN OURS?
THAT THEY WERE GIVEN A PROMISE
AND THAT DACA WAS A WAY FOR
THEIR CHOICE.
WE ALLOW PEOPLE FREEDOM --
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD -- BY THE
WAY, WHY WOULD YOU WANT SOMEONE
IN YOUR COUNTRY THAT IS NOT
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE THAT IS
DEMANDING OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
DON'T YOU WANT PEOPLE THAT ARE
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE AND ADD?
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO STAND UP FOR THEIR
RIGHTS.
I JOINED --
>> Tucker: WHY DO THEY HAVE --
>> I JOINED THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
IN PROTESTS THAT HAPPENED ON
SATURDAY FROM PEOPLE THAT WHO
WERE BORN AND RAISED IN THIS
COUNTRY AND HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
GENERATIONS THAT IS ONE OF THE
HALLMARKS OF OUR GREAT SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: BUT THEY'RE NOT
AMERICANS, THESE PEOPLE.
>> BUT THEY HAVE A VOICE.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO A VOICE.
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT FROM
HERE DOESN'T MEAN THE
CONSTITUTION -- THAT IS WELL
SETTLED LAW.
>> Tucker: IF YOU BROKE OUR LAW
TO GET HERE, YOU DON'T HAVE THE
INCOMPLETE -- RIGHTS.
RIGHTS.
WHEN WE LOOK TO POLARIZE THIS
CONVERSATION BY POINTING THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE, BROUGHT
HERE BY THEIR PARENTS, WITHOUT
THEIR CHOICE AND DEMONIZING
THEM.
WE HAVE --
>> Tucker: THEY BLOCKED THE
ENTRANCE TO DISNEYLAND.
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
SLOW DOWN.
THEY BLOCKED THE ENTRANCE TO
DISNEYLAND.
OKAY?
I DIDN'T DO THAT.
THEY DID THAT.
DO THEY BEAR ANY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR DOING THAT?
>> AND THERE ARE AMERICANS THAT
USE THEIR RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH
THIS COUNTRY.
WHETHER YOU'RE BORN HERE --
>> Tucker: DO YOU SEE THE
DIFFERENCE -- IT'S NOT A MATTER
OF BEING BORN HERE.
IT'S A MATTER OF CITIZENSHIP.
CITIZENSHIP IS MEANINGFUL TO
MOST AMERICANS.
>> AND THEY WANT TO BE ON A PATH
TO CITIZENSHIP.
THESE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE WASHING
HARD AND HAVE --
OF WEEKDAY BLOCKING DISNEYLAND.
DON'T TELL ME THEY'RE WORKING
OUT OF FIVE AMERICANS, 81% OF
AMERICANS WANT LESS LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
WHERE ARE THEIR INTERESTS IN THE
MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
FOUR OUT OF FIVE AMERICANS OF
ALL POLITICAL PARTIES WANT LESS
LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT?
IT DEMONSTRATES THAT WE NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB OF COMMUNICATING
HOW IMPORTANT IMMIGRATION IS TO
OUR CITIES AND TO OUR COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT A CITY
LIKE ALBANY, NEW YORK.
WE HAVE AN AGING POPULATION.
A LOT OF THE GROWTH HAPPENING IN
OUR CITY IS HAPPENING BECAUSE OF
FROM EMPLOYERS IS THAT THEY
CAN'T FIND PEOPLE TO WORK.
SO WE'VE GOT A REAL WORK FORCE
REGION.
IMMIGRATION IS HELPING TO FUEL
THAT WORK FORCE.
>> Tucker: I WONDER THOUGH, FOR
EXAMPLE -- I WAS JUST LOOKING AT
STATS PROVIDED BY THE ALBANY
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I THINK YOU'VE SAID BEFORE THAT
YOUR CITY IS 40% FOREIGN BORN.
>> NO, NO.
IT'S ABOUT 11% FOREIGN BORN.
WE HAVE ABOUT 40 LONGS --
>> Tucker: MY MISTAKE, A HIGH
NUMBER.
IN 2017 OF EIGHTH GRADERS IN
ALBANY SCHOOLS 0% QUALIFIED IN
CRISIS MUCH LARGER THAN ANYTHING
YOU'RE DESCRIBING.
I'M WONDERING WHERE THE OUTRAGE
IS HERE.
THE IMMIGRATION THAT WE HAVE
I'M JUST SAYING I WONDER WHY I
HAVE NEVER HEARD YOU AS OUTRAGED
ABOUT THAT AS YOU ARE ABOUT
ISN'T THAT A CRISIS?
0% OF EIGHTH GRADERS.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT'S ANOTHER CONVERSATION THAT
WE CAN HAVE ABOUT THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING TO PARTNER WITH OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE TURNING THAT AROUND.
BY BRINGING TOGETHER OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION, OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY, YOU KNOW, HEALTHCARE
SO THAT WE AND WE ARE ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES --
ENGLISH AS A FIRST LANGUAGE
HELPS OR HURTS THAT?
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH OUR NEW LANGUAGE
LEARNERS, WE'RE MAKING -- HAVING
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE HELPING
THEM TO --
>> Tucker: SO IT'S A PROBLEM
THAT YOU NEED TO SOLVE.
YOU CONCEDE IT'S A PROBLEM.
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE THE
PROBLEM BETTER BUT IT'S A
PROBLEM WHEN YOU IMPORT PEOPLE
THAT DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH AS A
FIRST LANGUAGE.
WHY WOULD YOU ADD THAT BURDEN TO
SCHOOLS WHERE 0% OF EIGHTH
GRADERS ARE PROFICIENT?
MATH?
>> THAT NUMBER IS MISLEADING.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CHALLENGES
THAT EXIST IN ANY SCHOOL
DISTRICT, IN ANY URBAN DISTRICT,
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON THE SCHOOL
THE COMMUNITY TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN SO THAT
I'M NOT ARGUING AGAINST ALL
IMMIGRANTS.
DOES IMPORTING MORE IMMIGRANTS
MAKE IT BETTER?
YOU CONCEDED IT DOESN'T.
>> I DON'T SEE IT AS MAKING IT
BETTER OR WORSE.
IT'S AN ASSET TO THE CITY, TO
SEE THAT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO GROW, TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT --
>> Tucker: SO WHAT IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER THEN?
IF BRINGING IN MORE PEOPLE FROM
THIRD WORLD COUNTRIES MAKES
ALBANY A BETTER CITY, IS GOOD
FOR YOUR SCHOOLS, GOOD FOR YOUR
ECONOMY, WHAT IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER?
COUNTRIES TO ALBANY FOR YOU TO
GET REALLY RICH?
>> SO THIS IS WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO STEP UP AND
DECIDE WHAT IMMIGRATION POLICY
IS GOING TO BE.
THAT HAPPENS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
>> Tucker: AS THE MAYOR, WHAT IS
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE ON H
1B VISAS.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE LARGEST SEMI
CONDUCTOR MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES IN THE CAPITOL
REGION.
GE'S R&D CENTER IS THERE.
I WORKED FOR A MEDICAL DEVICE
MANUFACTURER.
WE USED --
>> Tucker: WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT H1B VISAS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE POOR
DACA PEOPLE.
MY QUESTION WAS, IF MORE POOR
PEOPLE MAKES YOUR CITY RICHER
WHAT IS THE GOOD NUMBER --
>> I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
STATISTICS AND NUMBERS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE THERE AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE ARE THERE AND WE
NEED TO BE WELCOMING --
>> Tucker: IT'S HELPING US --
DEFINITELY HELPING TO US GROW